if the world warms by two degrees some
changes to the biosphere are no longer
gradual Greenland's glaciers are
disappearing so much ice has melted
polar bears struggle to survive
insects migrate in strange new
directions as a temperate climate moves
north in the US pine beetles kill off
the whitebark forests like grizzly bears
key source of food in the fall new
forests take root in Canada's melting
Tundra
the Pacific Islands of Tuvalu are lost
beneath the rising tides of global
warming
this could be our world plus two degrees
and two degrees of warming the impacts
in the marine ecosystem are going to be
much more severe we're likely to lose
the vast majority of the world's
tropical coral reefs it's a problem
that's keeping all of her Goldberg up
late into the night to some it might
seem almost incredible that we could
change something as fast as the ocean I
mean the Pacific Ocean I mean if you
just take that huge bowl of water how
could we change it a marine biologist at
the University of Queensland in
Australia overs tracking changes in
coral reefs they're acting a little bit
like a canary in the coalmine
- used to take a little bird down with
them and when the bird got sick they
knew to withdraw because there was gas
building up in the mind
well coral reefs you know beautiful by
diverse part of the earth and the very
fact that that's disappearing should
have all of us worried just like the
canary in the coal mine